we do have new details about the woman
who opened fire at YouTube's California
headquarters and why she may have chosen
that target police have identified the
shooter as 39 year-old Nasim Adam she's
from San Diego she shot and wounded
three people with a handgun before
apparently killing herself in several
videos posted online
Adam accuses YouTube of censoring her
videos and she expresses anger about the
company the gunfire yesterday afternoon
sent YouTube employees rushing from the
building for safety all three shooting
victims were hospitalized one in
critical condition John Blackstone is
outside the YouTube headquarters in San
Bruno California John good morning good
morning while police cordoned off this
area as officers continue their
investigation on youtubes campus here a
motive is still unclear but police say
there's no evidence that the shooter
knew any of the victims or that anyone
was specifically targeted police arrived
at YouTube's headquarters two minutes
after receiving reports of an active
shooter she was doing this YouTube
employee Diana iron spire says she heard
gunshots and saw the shooter from the
offices second-floor window
behind me over the patio and I saw her
was a woman and she was firing her and I
just said shooter heavily armed police
swarmed YouTube's campus and could be
seen searching employees at Barberini a
San Bruno police chief upon arrival
officers encountered numerous employees
fleeing from the building I was very
chaotic as you can imagine we conducted
a a quick immediate search of the
premises when police arrived at the
scene at 12:48 they found a wounded
victim at the building's front entrance
officers continued searching room by
room through the sprawling 200,000
square foot office complex within
minutes police say they found the
deceased shooter outside in a connected
courtyard I saw there's still a couple
people crouched behind tables so I went
to go look to see if you know they were
saw outside and then that's when I saw
someone like in front the doors lying on
the ground two other victims wounded by
the shooter took refuge in nearby
restaurants she got shot in the calf and
they took her into Carl's jr. where they
put her on the table we got a bunch of
cord I tied it above her leg to stop the
bleeding
YouTube's parent company Google says
it's cooperating with authorities in the
investigation there are questions about
how the woman gained access to this
building CBS News contributor Nicholas
Thompson was here at YouTube's
headquarters just about two weeks ago
and he says that well a badge is needed
to get into certain parts of the
building that there is no security or
metal detector as you go in the
building's main entrance Gail where a
lot of people will be rethinking
security today thank you very much John